hello and welcome to a championship
edition of The Bleacher Report fantasy
football show presented by State Farm my
name is Adam Levitan coming to you from
an undisclosed location here in the
great state of Florida as always joined
by Michael Leone who Lord knows what
Jersey he's wearing today Leone has
going tell the people what you're
wearing today all right we got a we got
a Steve Largent Jersey throwback
Seahawks you know if they beat the
Steelers it's another uh W for the bills
and the in the playoff hopes so that's
what we're rocking this week the people
watching have no idea who Steve largon
is I mean Stone Cold zero idea who Steve
LaRon is anyways it is championship week
if you guys are listening to this I
assume that you in your Championship job
well done big congrats on getting there
hopefully hopefully we can help you take
it down this weekend wait for some more
people to file in here go to some
questions from Chad first and by the way
the topic today will just be players who
we think will help you win your fantasy
Championship but to get to some chat
questions 27 Debo says do I start Ty
Chandler bjn Robinson notes bejn
Robinson is safer but needs upside to
win this one so really poor game for Ty
Chandler last week did s Salvage his day
with a touchdown but he did massively
out snap Alexander Madison which is kind
of what we expected now Tai Chandler
gets a much better matchup I mean you
can make a case that the Packers have a
bottom three defense bottom two defense
I mean their defense is really really
bad right now so it's an interesting
question Talent Gap is obviously very
wide Le only what do you think about
Bean versus Tai Chandler this week we
have them projected 0.1 points apart in
full PPR scoring right now so it's an
incredibly close decision one I'm sure
27 Debo will not regret no matter what
but I slightly lean Tai Chandler you
know bejan's in a tough rushing matchup
against the Bears they've really been
mixing in aler and Cat and as you noted
the matchup for Chandler is really good
against Green Bay I actually think
there's a little bit more upside if Nick
Mullins was starting this game I think
it'd be a clear tight Chandler for me
but with jiren Hall back there's there
is some systemic risk in that offense is
like not totally sure how it's going to
operate still lean
Chandler having surprisingly despite
being the the not as talented player a
little bit more upside here it's not
just that jiren hall there's more
systemic risk I mean this dude's going
to run I mean and he's going to run a
bunch and that's not and he runs around
the goal line that's not good for Tai
Chandler either we've seen DeAndre Swift
robbed of a ton of touchdowns this year
from Jaylen Herz blee 1962 says Jaylen
watd is out do I start Z Jones or
Christian Watson well blee ey I have
some Bleak news uh Christian Watson has
not returned to practice at all this
week and believe me I need Christian
Watson to play also but it's not looking
good I do think Z Jones will be back
this week and so you know it's not ideal
but with Christian Kirk out you could do
worse than Z Jones I think you got to go
that way Jazzy says can I trust the Jets
defense tonight or go after the Bears
defense on waivers so surprisingly mild
weather tonight for an almost New Year's
game
in Cleveland of course jets are facing
Joe Flaco who has been dropping back at
insane insane rates now will they be
forced into this many Joe Flaco backups
when you're facing Trevor Simeon and the
Jets offense I don't know meanwhile
Bears defense has been balling for sure
my gut is still the Jets here Le only
and hope that we get a lot of flacko
dropbacks and a bad flacko game but I
get that people don't want to go against
fler right now what do you think there
my gut is Jets defense as well I think
it's the more talented defense and like
sometimes people play for safety at
defense but the fact that Flaco's
dropping back A lot's actually a good
thing like he will make some mistakes he
will Chuck you have a little bit more
upside than you do Atlanta just pounding
the ball on the ground all day long you
can't get sacks on a handoff you can't
get interceptions on a handoff so I
think the Jets have a bit more upside
even though the team is in a worse spot
overall Cowboys for Life 94 oh you know
Tony Pard is down bad when Cowboys for
Life 94 is asking James Cook or Tony
Pard I mean believe me I'm on massive
tilt I I needed a Jame a Tony po
touchdown last week I honestly think and
you guys can go to my Twitter Adam
Levitan I tweeted this picture where it
looks like Tony per could have just
walked to the end zone if he went to the
pylon last week instead he decides to
cut it up field and gets a one-arm
tackle from a defensive back it was one
of the most pathetic going line runs
I've ever seen in my entire life in a
microcosm of Tony pards entire season so
I am biased here Leone you're biased as
well as a bills truther but I think this
has to be James cook for me but yeah
what do you think James Cook versus Tony
Pard I think it's cook you know good
home matchup for the bills they've
really shown that they will establish it
recently um if that's what's working and
the game script with them as huge
favorite certainly favors that the only
like the good thing for I think Rico do
is out this week which is you know
lowkey a good thing you know he's been
siphoning off a few touches here and
there sometimes some high value touches
so I still think there's hope for Tony
Pard I think you know again really close
I'd side with James cook but that that
is a good sign for Pard yeah I agreed
that that is better for Pard but man I
just have no confidence in this guy
whatsoever it would be definitely be
James cook for me all right let's get to
the main part of today's show show which
is players that we like this week maybe
some players you're considering on the
fence we didn't want to go with stars
obviously you guys know about all those
guys we tried to pick some on the fence
guys to consider starting this week we
will start with Mr Nico Collins and what
you get with Nico Collins this week is
CJ Stroud back and like I can't
overemphasize enough how important that
is CJ strad came into the NFL and
immediately elevated all the talent
around him and while I think n Collins
is a very good player he's only a really
great fantasy asset I think if CJ strad
is out there you also get Nico without
tank Dell and start to get bigger
projections on Nico through that and I
think it's way easier to throw the
football on Tennessee than it is to run
on them so Nico Collins I feel pretty
good about this week be sure you're
starting
him second one Leon you can go ahead
with that one yeah I'll go Trey MC ride
for Arizona here you know it is a tough
Team Matchup against Philadelphia but
the way you generally attack
Philadelphia is through the air you know
they're Stout against the Run not as
good against the pass Arizona's 10 and a
half Point dog so they're probably going
to have to throw due to game script
anyways and McBride's one of the few
tight ends that you can pencil in with
huge Target shares each week so you're
not just hoping for a touchdown you
actually have a legitimate floor to go
with ceiling with McBride because the
target volume so consistent for him um
he's at the point where he we're
projecting him basically as a top three
tight end each week almost regardless of
matchup and I think it's a plus spot for
him this week yeah I mean I know people
were disappointed last week I was
disappointed last week with only 31
yards but he still got eight targets
still caught six balls and the Bears
defense quietly has been stepping up a
lot lately way you beat the Eagles is
pass and also Eagles make like no
Investments or very little Investments
at linebacker spots and so they've been
getting beat up by tight ends for a long
time now Trey McBride certainly in play
all right for certainly in play for a
big game I hope I have a bunch of Trey
McBride I hope all
right we want to go back to your
questions now we're of course here for
the people Matt says CJ strad or Joe
flacko so one thing about flacko stuff
is we haven't seen him since his return
in a really difficult matchup this is a
really difficult matchup Jets defense
Jet's pass defense has been Elite pretty
much all year this is also a Revenge
spot for Joe Flaco if you believe in
Revenge spots I mean I think if Joe
Flaco would have stayed with the Jets
and as their backup for Aaron Rogers
they would have made the playoffs easily
this year but anyways I really like this
spot for CJ strad my gut is Stroud
especially with Amari Cooper banged up
we still don't have Word I mean it's
getting late here Leon I have not seen
any word
marer tonight and and if Mark Hooper
doesn't play that would be a big blow to
Joe flacko in my opinion but yeah this
would be sced for me what do you think
Leon honestly I don't think it's close I
think it's Stroud this Tennessee defense
you mentioned like they're easier to
throw against than to run against
they're pretty banged up too they have a
lot of injuries Stroud's shown a big
ceiling all season long and you know Flo
story is great but he's run a little bit
pure you know last week they don't have
a kicker and he throws some touchdown on
like fourth Downs they would kick field
goals on because you know they had no
choice and he's played well don't get me
wrong he still would have had a good
game but I don't like it when you have a
bad matchup against a defense like the
Jets but you're still favored by a lot
of points so you're probably not going
to Chuck that combination to me isn't a
very high upside combination so um you
know black has been forced to throw a
lot the last three starts I think the
attempts come down somewhat meaningfully
this
week somebody's gonna have to explain to
me why why if a ker gets hurt in the
middle of a game you don't have a backup
plan this is a billion doll company
think think of the Cleveland Browns as a
billion dollar company they're probably
worth like four billion you're a four
billion dollar company and you don't
have a backup plan if your kicker gets
hurt in game it's insane to me I mean we
have a if I get hit by a b if I get hit
by a bus tomorrow we have a backup plan
and trust me we're not we're not a$ four
billion dollar company I mean this
insane to me I I don't get it it's it's
a feature not a bug no more field goals
we're just going for it every
time analytics nerds get what they want
seriously D bush says Drake London or
Rasheed Shahed awesome spot for Rasheed
Shahed this week the way you beat the
Tampa Bay Buccaneers is to throw the
football and throw it down the field
Rasheed Shahed is one of if not the best
deep threat in the entire league
meanwhile Drake London we know the story
very very talented player however
Falcons ideally want to be very runhe
heavy now I did think last last week
with Tay hinei they threw it 33 times in
a game they might not have had to throw
it 33 times they were still run heavy
but they still didn't have to throw it
33 times the Shahed stuff is high
ceiling low floor to me and I would
think about what you need in your lineup
do you need to try to find someone who
can go off for 20 or 25 points in this
game but yeah Leon what do you think
about straight up London or Shahed yeah
I think you got to go this ceiling with
Shahed here just a lot higher in this
game environment
all right last one I mean I know we just
said you got to start Nico Collins but W
Max says Nico Collins or Mike Evans uh
this is another hashtag how rich another
hashtag humble brag question because I
would love to start both of these guys
by the way for Mike Evans no Marsh lore
this week who has been uh Mike Evans
longtime Nemesis there cornerback for
the Saints so I can't sit Mike Evans
given the year that he's had I love Nico
Collins this week week but I don't think
I can sit Mike Evans dude is just too
good any problems with that one
Leone I think it's close um I think
you'll feel worse if you you sit Mike
Evans and it goes bad than if you sit
Nico and it goes bad just because all
the consistency that Mike Evans has had
but our projections do have Nico
slightly ahead in this one as you noted
at him with tank D out the targets pout
run for niik are just so so massive and
it's a really good spot for Houston to
put
points all right let's get back to the
players we like here kind of fringy
players we like this week number three
is going to be Mr Brock pie and I know a
lot of people out there have given up on
Brock pie after one game uh that would
be a mistake Brock pie I think is going
to go out and absolutely shred this
Commander's defense on Sunday one of if
not the most efficient quarterback
seasons in the history of the NFL Now
facing the worst pass defense in the
entire NFL I know Leon's been battling
all the losers on Twitter who say Brock
pie should not even be in the MVP
conversation do you want to say anything
about your boy Brock pie here to the
bleacher I mean I don't know if he
should win the MVP but you gotta at
least consider him a reasonable Choice
given that he's on Pace for one of the
most efficient passing seasons in NFL
history has the volume numbers to go
with it obviously you got to take into
account team context the scheme the
players around him supporting him but
when there's not really a clear choice
he's at least reasonable for me and I'm
glad you let me talk about perie because
number four on our list I feel like you
just set me up for absolute foul I feel
like this is a joke number four on this
list basic just the guy you tell me to
bump in projections every week and you
know you you set up the order so that I
have to talk about him so Marvin Mims
the the key here is that Portland Sutton
is expected to miss this game due to a
concussion Jared Judy has been
absolutely awful so and they're playing
the Chargers which is a really burnable
pass defense I think the way that MIM
skill set sets up sets up really well to
face the Chargers the problem is that
even last week after courton Sutton went
out very early we saw a little Jordan
Humphrey run more routes we saw Jerry
Judy run more routes and we saw Brandon
Johnson run more routes than Marvin Mims
and then today today right before the
show Marvin Ms pops up on the injury
report with a hamstring issue which was
incredibly tilting so this is one we
need to watch closely but I do think
there's something here with Jared stum
and these wide receivers there's
something here with one of them if
you're very desperate my favorite would
still be Judy if Mims plays you my
second favorite but if Mims ends up
missing you can go maybe down to guys
like Lil Jordan or Brandon Johnson these
would be desperation plays if you need
them not ideal but yeah it's just a spot
that I want people to be thoughtful of
yeah I do think like if you're in a
deeper League or you've just lost guys
due to injuries sometimes it's better
though to take a shot on a Marvin Mims
who like you can win these weekly
matchups more so with a random ceiling
performance then you will with maybe
some guy that you know is going to go
like three for 30 and get you six points
and it's not really going to move the
needle like take on a little bit more
risk with Mims you get the upside as
Adam said like you know you're not
starting them over legitimate wide
receivers but um there's definitely
spots for
it all right let's go back to the chat
here for some questions Jen Kar says
Baker Mayfield or Derek Carr now baker
has really been playing well and I
actually think Baker is gonna earn
himself a really good contract this off
season I do think that no marshan
ladimore matters here for the Saints and
they know these guys are facing
each other you get alive and Shahed in
pretty good spots on the other side I
think this one is close I suspect we
have a better projection on Baker
Mayfield I don't have it in front of me
I'm not sure if you do Leon but any
thoughts on
Baker versus Derek Carr here yeah we do
have a better projection on Baker in
this one Tampa Bay with a little bit
higher team total I think the passing
touchdown upsides a bit higher for Baker
too just the way these teams can operate
in the Red Zone you know we don't see it
every week but once in a while car will
get tmed down there and he's I know he
had he's had a good run recently but
he's had a lot of Red Zone struggles
this year so basically that pass
touchdown Equity is the
tiebreaker Caillou says Devonte Smith or
Chris Godwin um it's hard to find a
better matchup for dvon Smith that said
it's hard to find a better matchup for
anyone on the Eagles than they'll face
this week when they face the Arizona
Cardinals and so I actually think Swift
has the best matchup but certainly
they'll be able to throw the ball if
they need to through AJ Brown and
Devonte Smith Chris Godwin has role has
really ticked up I don't know if you
noticed this Leone uh Chris Godwin's
wife like went on Instagram and complain
directly to Dave Canales about Chris
Godwin's role and since then Chris
Godwin has been getting peppered with
targets I me I can't believe it Canal
has listened to Chris Godwin's wife or
Baker listened to Godwin's wife that
said uh for me here it is pretty easily
Devonte Smith Leon any thoughts on
Devonte versus Chris Godwin yeah I mean
Godwin's been great recently I you know
you got to go to the top go straight to
the top she knows how to get it done but
uh it's still Devonte Smith in just an
absolutely awesome matchup the
efficiency upsides too big to pass for
him Eno Says Z flower is coming off of
that monster game in the game what
should have been the game of the year
Ravens 49ers or rahee moard who is just
scoring touchdowns at an absolute Ely
outrageous rate now it is hard for us in
projection I think to capture what
Raheem Mo's touchdown role really is
like this guy is kind of breaking the
model in terms of how often he's scoring
touchdowns if he doesn't score
touchdowns though you're in a lot of
trouble but man guy scoring them at such
a high rate any thoughts on this one Z
flowers versus Raheem moer I kind of
like Z here I think you know it's a
tougher matchup for Miami than usual
against this really good Baltimore
defense so that hurts that touchdown
upside for mostard it's still there but
it's not as strong as it is on a normal
week and then the flip side for
Baltimore they're less likely to be you
know leading these games that they've
dominated on defense special teams and
whatnot so I think you're going to see
more overall pass volume than we usually
see out of them even last week when they
smacked 49ers around they threw the ball
a little bit more than usual I think
that happens again so I'm going to give
a lean towards Z flowers but it's one of
those things like format matters quite a
bit you know when you're comparing wide
receiver running back full PPR give me Z
standard League you know give me moster
if it's in between half PPR I'm gonna
side with Z
still all right let's get into
everybody's favorite portion of the
program the fantasy bundles presented by
State Farm where bundling your home and
auto insurance is just another way to
save with the personal price plan all
right it's championship week shout out
to you shout out to everyone who is
still alive these are players if you're
grinding perhaps
DFS or if you're in any other kind of
format where you need some correlation
this week in other words if the
quarterback goes off well he's likely to
drag on some really likely to drag on
some pass catchers with him so we'll go
through our favorite five Stacks or
bundles for the week now I'll start with
one we already mentioned Brock pie to
Brandon auk I mean this Commander's
defense was bad then they gave then they
traded away montz
sweat and Chase young and they just
can't get any pressure on the
quarterback and they have no talent in
the secondary and teams just do whatever
they want in the passing game against
the commanders every single week it's
been quiet for Brandon Iuka relatively
quiet at least compared to Debo recently
but this is a good spot for them to get
Brandon auk going here so Brock py to
Brandon iuk the first bundle of the week
Le only you can go ahead with bundle
number two yeah I'll go to the second
bundle and we've got Derek Carr to Chris
alive this Tampa Bay defense they' been
middle of the pack against both the pass
and the run but the way they play teams
choose to attack them through the air
right now we have them with the third
highest pass R overe expectation against
which just basically means relative to
what you would think based on the score
based on the down and distance teams are
throwing at the third highest rate
against Tampa Bay so that's a really
good sign for this New Orleans passing
game and um yeah you know no Michael
Thomas there I think it's really good
spot for La who started to command more
of that Alpha Target share
recently speaking of alpha Target share
third bundle of the week is a no-brainer
Jaylen Herz to AJ Brown we're over
Market uh in terms of what we think on
Jaylen Hertz passing projection this
week I think people overestimate the
chances of a blowout right you know
people always think oh it's going to be
a blowout Jaylen Herz is going to have
to throw that's not really the way that
a lot of games play out you can't be so
certain number one and you can't be sure
that when they're up four touchdowns
that they're not going to continue to
throw AJ Brown remains I like Devonte
Smith but AJ Brown to me Remains the
easy Alpha there in Philly and so
probably one of if not the highest
upside stacks of the week is going to be
Jaylen Brown uh Jaylen Herz to AJ Brown
the only go ahead with number four
number four Matthew Stafford to auka
nakua and we get a really high team
total for the Rams this week even out of
their Dome traveling to New York playing
outside they still have a team total of
25 which is quite High the Giants below
average defense they're 20th in pass
Rank dvoa and Stafford recently with cup
and puka getting his guys healthy the
efficiencies come up so I really like
the upside here you also get a little
bit of narrative street with puka
chasing the rookie wide receiver record
definitely within Striking Distance and
you know sometimes when these choices
are tight I do like to go to teams that
are playing for their playoff lives and
the stuff really matters and the Rams
are one of those teams yeah for sure
actually check the weather there I mean
it's crazy it's like mild in East
Weatherford New Jersey on Sunday also
which is I feel like you're you're mad
that you can't get mad at the weather
fearmongers they're not out this week
they're not at they're not yeah they've
been silenced uh okay last bundle Justin
fields to DJ Moore so I don't think it's
like the best spot ever for Justin
fields or anything like that but Cole KD
is hurt and I kind of think Cole KT is
gonna miss that game and that's low-key
important for DJ Moore Cole KT has
hogged a bunch of Red Zone targets
Justin Fields looks for Cole KT around
the end zone I think we can get a little
bit more touchdown Equity from DJ Moore
this week and so Fifth and final State
Farm bundle of the week is indeed Justin
Fields the Dual threat and his favorite
Target the alpha
DJ
Moore all
right man last State Farm bundle of the
weeks sad times let's go back to chat
here Alex says Austin
Eckler or David Montgomery ah I just
this Chargers team man if I was Austin
Eckler after the Chargers refused to pay
me now nobody's playing kenan's not
playing Herbert's not playing R of the
playoffs I'm sure Eckler is going to
play it out played out hard because he's
a good dudee and he does the right thing
but I just don't feel good about this
Chargers offense at all on the other
hand Dave Montgomery's been getting out
played by jir Gibbs largely and he has
to faced the Cowboys this week I still
think I I still think I feel a little
better about Montgomery I know we have a
better projection on eckar though Leon
what do you think about that
one yeah I think we might end up
lowering our Eckler projection a little
bit this is tough for me I think like
all the tiebreakers go the way of
Montgomery but we do have eckar ahead
just that pass game role it's such a
huge difference if you can catch four to
five balls for even 20 to 30 yards and
you start basically a touchdown ahead of
David Montgomery who you know is maybe
going to catch one ball maybe two so
it's really difficult
and if you're looking for some positive
signs with Eckler you know similar to
what we saw with Antonio Pierce in Las
Vegas they went back to Josh Jacobs he
played a ton when we had you know the
coach firing
McDaniels there we get Staley fired
interim coach comes in Eckler snaps
immediately way back up in that game
against Buffalo they did show some signs
of life so like full PPR I think you
might just have to take Eckler because
that pass catching floor but anything
else you know give me Montgomery and
what could be a shootout and he's just
way more likely to find the end zone
Travis says Noah brown or Josh Palmer
Josh Palmer actually miss practice I
believe uh today but I think I like Noah
Brown more anyways again no t you get CJ
strad back so I think that's a pretty
easy one Noah Brown who I thought was
just like a blocking type wide receiver
has had some huge games and by the way I
got into a no one cares but I got into a
high stakes head-to-head DFS game and
this guy showed up with Noah Brown
against me when case Keenan was
quarterback and I was like oh man we're
Printing and uh yeah Noah Brown went off
so yes Noah Brown I think I've changed
my mind dude can play skins for Life
says Rashid rice or DJ Moore this is a
tough one I like both these guys this
would be another how rich situation but
I understand how you have this one
because Rashid rice likely came off
waivers to you any thoughts on this one
Leon Rashid rice or DJ Moore I think I'd
go Rashid rice it's pretty close uh
again we'll track the KT situation that
could boost things a little bit more in
the favor of DJ Moore but this KC you
know you know while they're struggling
they've really leaned in to Rashid rice
his Target shares the last five weeks
29% 27% 23% 24% 27% we haven't seen that
out a casc wide receiver in a long time
and I think they bounce back they're
going to throw so much more than Chicago
to which is really you know the big
tiebreaker in all of this if if rice can
see a similar Target share to DJ Moore
then it's gonna be rice every time
because the quarterback and the offense
that he's attached
to last question from chat here comes
from sniper he says Gardner m
or Joe Flo
so I thought that Raiders were a good
matchup right but since Antonio Pierce
has taken over their defense has been
flying around and they have some Talent
there that I think they're building on
and so I'm not sure that season long
data on Raiders defense is what we
should be using that said obviously we
talked about Joe Flaco's very difficult
matchup here as well what do you think
about minu versus
flacko I think it's really close we have
muu projected a little bit higher but
you know this isn't like the the stoud
Flaco question where there's a big gap
if it's this close and you kind of want
to ride the hot hand I really couldn't
fault you it's a little bit of a coin
flip to me I think I'd personally
probably play muu but um you know just
with the team total and that game
environment being a bit better I think
this this Jets Cleveland game could end
up kind of gross tonight and I think
getting Michael Pitman back is pretty
big for mshu too so I'll go muu also um
especially if Amari Cooper is out
tonight all right two more players we
really like this week as starts either
Isaiah Peko number this will be number
five on our list here either Isaiah
Pacho or Claude Edwards Air Isaiah P's
helmet came off twice in like a five
play span last week the second
time but my God man Buckle the chin
strap you know Buckle the Buckle the
chin strap anyways Cincinnati
worst defense the NFL I mean them the
commanders the Packers it's a joke so no
matter who starts here if Pacho if he's
active CH if he's not awesome awesome
play against the Bengals maybe you could
even get CH off your wire if needed Leon
I give you the honor of doing our last
note here of the entire season to wrap
it up yes let's go Kelvin Ridley who had
a huge second half last week with
Jacksonville trailing and again playing
these desperate teams that really need
to win like the Rams you know against
the Giants you get the Jaguars in
another spot against Carolina where it's
pretty beatable opponent but they can't
afford to take the foot off the gas they
need to win this game not only to try
and win the division but just to make
the playoffs in general the way things
have trended 22 team total for
Jacksonville on the rise from previous
recent weeks and again with Christian
Kirk out there he's going to be the
alpha Target share guy he's the guy I
Look to In The End Zone really like
Calvin Ridley this week all
right there you have it our six players
for championship week to start Nico
Collins Trey McBride Brock pie Marvin
Mims if you're desperate watch the
injury there either Isaiah Pacho or
Clyde Clyde Edwards aair whoever gets
the start and Calvin
Ridley we'll wrap up the season here
with a few chats because
we love you all habz Tings says Bree
Hall Kenneth Walker or aan up again he
says he's up against CMC this week I
mean we have I think the biggest
projection we've ever had in the history
of projections on CMC this week but
anyways I think aan is a tough start
right now um Bree Hall is a tough start
this week I'm tempted to say Kenneth
Walker here but man this is a tough one
Leon what do you think about Hall Walker
hm yeah I think I'd go Bree Hall here
you know I do not love the match up
against Cleveland nobody does but they
just have such little offense they have
to manufacture things through him and he
can get you there you know he's not
gonna have a game like he did last week
against Washington but he had that game
I think it was against Miami not last
time out but two times ago where they
just had to utilize him in the past game
and I think he had like 12 targets or
something last week just like an insane
amount of work in the past game and to
me that just gives him an upside the
other guys can't hit even with the
matchup being quite difficult Kings
X-Man says Terry mclen or jayen Reed so
I think jayen Reed's gonna play on
Sunday night I don't know for sure
meanwhile McLaren gets jacobe per
setback now they do have to play San
Francisco I think it would be Jaden Reed
for me if I knew he was 100% healthy so
I think monitor the injury report there
if there's any doubt on how close to
100% Jaden Reed is though you got to go
mclen otherwise I think it would be
Jaden Reed for me Brian says Dallas Gard
or Isaiah likeley I think you want to
play Eagles against the Cardinals as
much as I like Isaiah likeley I've been
Isaiah likeley guy going back to the
Coastal Carolina days but you gotta play
your Eagles here I think L would you
agree on Goddard over likely yeah I
think there's a little bit more volume
overall for G than likely and you know
team total is astronomical we have
Arizona
inflating tight end scoring specifically
too so I like GD here Cowboys for life
is back with David and joku or Travis
Kelce
so I think and this is all narrative
stuff that is not data- driven
whatsoever but Travis Kelce seemed legit
angry throwing his helmet around yelling
at Mahomes yelling at Reed goes on his
podcast starts cursing everyone out
they're losing I mean it strikes me as a
spot where they really try to get Travis
Kelce going so I know en joku has been
awesome in this match against the Jets
though I think I'd be okay going with
Travis Kelce
there yeah I would go yeah yeah I would
go Kelsey there Neil t24 asks Bree Kiren
white or Gibbs who would you sit leaning
Bree man that is an absolutely loaded
running back room and I have no issues
sitting Bree you know I just said I
liked him in that other setup but Kiron
Williams Rashad white jir Gibbs are
three of the better running backs in all
fantasy right now you cannot sit Kiron
he's an absolute lock to start I really
think Gibbs is too and the way this
Dallas Detroit can game can go and yeah
I think Bree is fine as to sit in that
four running back room that is quite
Stellar easy easy BR sit in my opinion
uh reek says Dak Prescott or Jaylen Herz
I love the spot for Dak I mean you it's
difficult to run the football on the
Detroit Lions very easy to pass against
them but there's just no way I can sit
Jaylen Herz and the tush push against
Arizona here I think it would be Jaylen
Herz for me and I know we have that in
projection but man those are two of the
best quarterback plays of the entire
week for
sure yeah yeah Reed mon asks Calvin
Ridley or Nico Collins I have both and
they're both both on your list so yeah
two good guys to choose from but it's
Nico Collins for me uh he's been way
more consistent than Calvin Ridley over
the course of the season so I think it's
a great spot for Ridley expecting a lot
of things out of him but uh Nico is on
another tier for me especially with tank
Dell out CJ strout in perfect
combination perfect matchup so Nico is
one of the best wide receiver plays of
anybody on the entire
week all
right
thank you to everyone who tuned in to
bleach report we this kind of came out
of nowhere bleach report asked us if we
want to do the show once a week and uh
we said sure and it turned out to be a
ton of fun so hopefully you guys who
tuned in every week enjoyed it and uh
got something out of it thanks to
everyone behind the scenes at bleach
report for inviting us and making
everything so smooth thanks to State
Farm for sponsoring the show most of all
there would be no show if you guys
didn't sit here and watch us mess around
and talk about fantasy football so
appreciate all of you being here all
season
wall if you want to follow us actually H
you know what we're gonna be doing this
all
offseason Adam Lan on Twitter two hats1
Mike on the Twitter machine you can find
us on YouTube iTunes anywhere else you
find you can find search our name or
establish the run four Leone four
everybody at bleach report for everybody
State Farm I am Adam good luck
everybody